so uh forrest you're you're based out of
minneapolis i live in minneapolis for
the time being
for the time being and you've got to see
a lot of what's been going on
we got the story from the star tribune
here we go brooklyn center passes police
reform package bravo
uh black lives matter they've won this
one the failed leadership of brooklyn
center has caved
one of the things they're going to be
doing an unarmed
civilian traffic enforcement division
here's my favorite thing civilian mm-hmm
are police civilians technically yes
technically no i'm i'm not going to be
able to
answer that one because it's it i think
you could make the argument in many ways
that they're functionally neither right
now
functionally neither they're
functionally neither because i mean sure
they have you have
they're not citizens in the sense that
they work for the government that's
where do we make that distinction either
is another question because that's i
think that's a very modern
way of thinking yeah because a soldier
is not considered a citizen but he's
still a citizen of the country he's a
civilian
he's not considered a civilian yeah so
they but they're citizens they're
citizens civilians yeah sorry
yeah they're they're you know combatants
they're they're armed forces
and uh so conventionally the answer is
no
but it so i would i would i would say
that if you're talking from a military
perspective the answer is yes
they're not going in foreign war they're
literally living in a small town and
dealing with local domestic law
they're civilians so the line gets
blurred because you have you have
when you talk about the police you're
you're talking about a very large
swath of people right you've got your
small town sheriff
and you've got cia you've got fbi
you've got bortak you've got people who
have
who are much more look much more
militant than most people don't see them
and they're are they both considered the
police well so let's get in the meat
potatoes here
they they've successfully reformed their
police and it's it's
beyond what i would consider because
i've said we need reform but i'm usually
talking about
creating more divisions like an unarmed
traffic enforcement
okay well maybe if the idea uh
if the idea is like you see someone
commit a traffic violation you write
down their license plate and they mail
them a ticket
that's something they've been talking
about doing but what do you think would
happen if
someone you know an unarmed civilian
tries pulling over
let's say there's a guy and uh maybe
he's at a party
and he wakes up and he's got a gun and
he goes to one of the people
who owns like one of the people who
lives there and then he says give me all
your money and then shows that he's got
a gun
let's say that's that's the person and
now this person is wanted for that crime
which is a funny
let's say they're driving and the
unarmed person pulls them over
for by whatever means the division is
able to do it the lights turn on i guess
they have some kind of car
and they get out what do you think
happens to a person in a situation like
this
you do have a disparity of power and you
also have a disparity of the duty so the
is it the duty of the unarmed civilian
to pull somebody over
or is it just a privilege of their
position
right so please please stop yeah i mean
you're powerless to employ it but are
you is there the burden the onus of the
state on you to go do it do you have a
quota
oh well there's more people drunk
driving in our neighborhood right now
yeah they are they're all armed and i'm
not right you're like what are you going
to do voters are bad
you know so it's the bureaucratic
problem i feel like this is the opening
the door to defund the police completely
one of the and it's kind of funny too
because one of the ways police get
funding is their tickets
and i'm not a fan especially when they
do quotas yeah so
now it's like they're being defunded by
taking away their ability to issue
traffic violations
i think it can be seen as a lot more
sinister too so you take your example
earlier
you they they see you commit a a
violation or they
put up traffic cameras and they see you
run a red light then they send a ticket
to your house which you cannot fight
or if you try to fight it it's going to
cost you time and money so you just
sort of now have to pay it but most
people do but if you don't
then they send armed people with guns to
your house
now you have a position of creating that
pipeline of going from um
i don't like you i write you a ticket
for something that could be bogus could
be legitimate
it goes to your house knowing that
you're not going to pay it
and then you instead of you and then and
then
you don't fight it this is bro we're
starting now they can search your house
now they can search your house now they
can seize your property this is called
um look at what this is already in
effect in london
wow right you go to london you run a red
light you park in the wrong place you
will have a ticket sent to your house
and you can't fight it well you can and
then if you don't pay it the cops show
up
and now you've got some kind of crime
they can let us in
it creates a paper trail it's it's it's
um it's crime by bureaucracy not now if
if they pull you over while you're
driving you get to take it don't pay
they can still go to your house and
arrest you and go into your house
yes but there was somebody there to
witness it that is the purpose of
american policing is that a
person has to do it i think though in
the end this would
increase the likelihood of these because
i once got uh
i once got in the mail two tickets from
chicago final determination they said
and i was like what is this i had gotten
two parking tickets for parking outside
of my dad's place in chicago but i had a
permit i had a parking permit
i guess a cop somebody wrote me two
tickets
never put them on my car i never got
notice of them until it was a
final determination and so when i got it
i called and said what is this i have a
permit to park where i did and they were
like sir it's too late you lost your
chance to fight the ticket
so imagine you get pulled over all right
let's you get pulled over you get to
take it you don't pay they they can
eventually come to your house maybe to
serve a warrant for failure to appear or
something like that
but let's say you never even knew you
did anything wrong let's say you didn't
do anything wrong
let's say you were driving right and one
of these unarmed people was just like
hey blue stop sign as far as i'm
concerned
you get you gotta take in the mail you
never realize it came in the mail you're
like i don't know these are you throw in
the trash
then one day they show up at your house
and you're like what's happening
when there's when there's an interaction
between you and the officer
i think there's you know likelihood
you're going to be aware of what's
happening
this will probably increase the
likelihood cops start showing up to
people's homes
and i can only imagine that would
maintain the same uh
ratio of violent encounters it's not
going to get better that's for sure
i mean it's not it's because now you're
going to take the
the cultural perception of the police as
a threat in certain areas and you're
going to
cross that you're going to paint that
across the whole population right but
apparently i was reading this and they
they are going to pull people over
yes so i can only imagine that people
are going to be like
you get pulled over and a guy walks up
in like a polo and khakis
and he's like excuse me sir you are
speeding i'm supposed to write you a
who are you a cop no sir i'm i'm not a
cop later
yeah or what obligation do i have to
stop for someone's not a cop i mean are
you just going to look back in your
mirror and say it's a red and yellow
light not a red and blue light so i
might as well just drive home
oh i live in a gated community you're
not allowed in here so if you come in
here i'm gonna call the actual cops to
tell you to not come in
i think it's funny i think it's funny
these people go around like smashing up
windows starting fires
we saw what happened right right now in
minneapolis they're they're
people are freaking out they're
demanding more cops they're increasing
the budgets
and then this one town brooklyn center
which is like north you just like
basically do north
all of a sudden they're like we're gonna
do the opposite we're gonna we're gonna
you know carpet launch
yeah i mean brooklyn center is gonna get
eaten by minneapolis it's gonna
get folded in i mean has that happened
recently
is it because folded in like it's it's
it's it's within the counties
it brooklyn center is is essentially
minneapolis
so what's what's it like living in
minneapolis is it is the apocalyptic
wasteland we all uh believe it is
because we watch nothing but internet
videos
it's not completely the apocalypse
apocalyptic wasteland um it's not the
but it is basically uh it's closer to
mosul
it's yeah it feels a lot more like being
in kandahar than it does like being in
america
but do you mean that for real like yeah
i mean it's not quite the same i'm not
driving an armored vehicle around
but i definitely there are definitely
like we have new sop standard operating
procedures amongst us and our friends
and our family like
you actually served though you were yeah
i was in the military
so so just discuss probably a lot of
people like he has no idea what he's
talking about minneapolis
no you're actually no i i have had the
uh
privilege of being in the armed forces
for a while that's a great time what did
you do in the military i was a ranger
army ranger
so it was a great time so now uh being
back home
and uh it's like what similar
not it's not as bad yeah i mean no one's
burning tires uh
to block the roadways for three months
of the year
there's an autonomous zone where they're
like we do have an autonomous barricades
and threaten people with violence
so in the same way there are places that
we just don't go
like there are roads you don't take no
go zones there's there's there is
there's definitely like
hey i we communicate my family we
communicate and it's like hey
i'm going to go get groceries okay cool
i mean that's kind of normal for some
people
but we're definitely more conscious
about what we're looking at
what what threats we're looking for what
kind of concerns we have and then we
have a little network of people that we
that are all friends and and
families in in the twin cities that were
all looking out for each other is this
new like this behaviors and these these
offensive
tactics it absolutely initiated last
year when the riots started
we it was we spontaneously set it up we
just called all the people that we knew
we built a
kind of a network through social media
conversation or through signal or
through
text messages and we established ways
that we talked to each other
so that we could very effect effectively
verify rumors so one of the worst things
that happened during the riots
uh last year not this year was
essentially the
entirety of social media became
um an advertisement for non things that
aren't happening
the the white supremacists are coming
down from new brighton the
these people are coming from here we
just saw this thing happen and it was
like
everyone was on so high alert that they
were spreading rumors so quickly
which added to the fervor it added to
the
the terror in the sense and so what the
first thing
one of the things that we had to do as a
community is
by our own volition by our own choice
verify information ourselves
so okay if someone's saying that the
this is on fire or they're moving
towards
one of the one of the concerns that they
had last year was if the police
provide a strong enough presence in
defending
of precinct or they harden targets in
like heart when they mean hardened
target like
make it difficult for people to loot and
riot in certain areas they're going to
move
into the residential area right so the
moment we heard that it was like okay
how can we verify that information
because that sounds a lot like hearsay
but it also has a big threat
so you're basically creating like a
neighborhood watch is that what happened
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's it's an
honor
yeah it's a neighborhood watch
unofficial it's like you know your chat
group
remember when i was talking about this
maybe like a week or two ago
when i said what's going to start
happening is there's more violence
you'll see the formation of like local
community groups
exactly they'll start texting each other
hey i heard this are you all right
you know there'll be text groups and
it's going to escalate from there
yeah and we took it a step further of
having triggers and conditions
or conditions and appropriate responses
so like in the event that x happens we
do y
right in the event that we see this
happen so like if the protest goes to
this precinct we go to this person's
house and get their wife and child out
and move them out of out of the city to
put them into a safe house
and we did that we had to do we had to
do exactly that you mentioned earlier
said for the time being
so you're getting out aren't you yeah
we're looking at moving out of state
there's not there's not a i mean our
families are
are there but there's not a lot of
reason to live in minneapolis right now
it doesn't it does not look like a
bright future
everybody's going to texas i guess texas
is a big one
yeah it's kind of crazy when you when
you mention like these streets you don't
go down
that's like a new thing since the start
of the riots that's why i asked you yeah
i mean the term minnesota nice is not
entirely
pejorative it also does mean that like
generally speaking you can drive through
most of the city and not be
in actual fear for your life but when i
go to a place and i see a roadblock with
armed people that
just by looking at them know that they
have no idea what they're doing with
that firearm
given it's their right to have it but i
know that they're not gonna they don't
know what they're doing with it i'm not
gonna put myself in the position
of no reward and all risk thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you